the bavarian palace of haran kimse a
beautiful and rather unusual backdrop
for the meeting of bavarian state
premiere marco zure and angela merkel
the relationship between the two hasn't
always been this cordial
the day started with a picturesque and
well orchestrated boat trip to the
island of haran kinsey
much more filmable than a more
convenient helicopter flight would have
been
that was followed by a ride in a
horse-drawn carriage
the pair resembling a regent with her
crown prince
but angela merkel doesn't want to
comment on the question
on everyone's lips
concerning the issue of my successor i
want to observe a certain restraint
which means that i won't comment on the
question in any way
more than half of germans think marcus
zuda would be a good candidate
his approval ratings shot up during the
corona crisis
zura definitely turned this into a
compliment and says it's
all thanks to the chancellor
that germany got through this crisis
better than other countries is down to
the influence
and leadership of the chancellor
angela merkel's trip to bavaria was a
display of
harmony pictures like these certainly
won't hurt bavaria state premier
on the road to a possible candidacy for
chancellorship
let's go to our chief political
correspondent melinda crane who is
following
uh this story for us hi melinda so we
have seen the pictures a very amicable
and grand visit which is rather unusual
for for mackel who's known for her
her sober appearances
that's true uh but of course it wasn't
the chancellor herself who chose these
settings but rather her host
however it's unusual for precisely that
reason
this is the same politician who during
the election campaign of 2018
made it clear that he would prefer that
the chancellor that chancellor mackel
not
visit him but was very happy to receive
a visit from the much more conservative
chancellor of austria this was at a time
when these two parties the chancellor's
christian democrats and its bavarian
sister
party the christian social union which
uh is mr serdis party
when they were scarcely on speaking
terms so
what has changed well uh mr cerda has
moved toward the middle of the political
spectrum and distanced himself from the
right-wing populism
of his predecessor and frankly a winner
loves a winner both certa and mackel
emerged
from the corona crisis looking very
strong indeed
the ratings that you mentioned they are
largely attributable to the fact that
both showed
very clear disciplined leadership to try
to nip corona in the bud
very interesting so melinda does this
mean marcus zuda is now
michael's hand-picked successor
no it doesn't i think when she uh tries
to
play her cards close to her vest that
she absolutely means that she had a
hand-picked
successor that was the woman who is now
the defense minister under great krump
karen bauer
that did not work out well at all so i
think that the chancellor is very much
uh now
uh doing a wait and see melinda
i mean can we expect that zurita would
throw his hat into the ring
and how might he do that it's quite
likely but i think there's an element of
wait and see on the part of
surah as well it may be that he would
have preferred to
wait until 2025 to throw his hat into
the ring he keeps saying that he really
loves bavarian wants to say
stay there on the other hand he also
says things like it's not my fault if
everybody's talking about me
i'm not the one who's putting those
stories out there
almost everybody expects that he will be
a candidate but if he sees
the ratings the polls turning downward
for the conservatives it is possible
that he will
then make his assertions about wanting
to stay in bavaria
even more enthusiastically all right
that's
belinda crane our chief political
correspondent here in dw on that story
thank you so much for that melinda
you